On November 18th, 1928, Mickey Mouse was
introduced to the world in the film
Steamboat Willie. But this may be one of
the last birthdays Mickey celebrates as
the intellectual property of Disney.
Copyrights for the popular character are
set to expire on January 1st, 2024. Mickey
might have become public property sooner
except that each time the copyright on
Steamboat Willie was set to lapse, Disney
and others pushed Congress to lengthen
US copyright terms. By 1998, works of
corporate authorship were exclusive
company property for 95 years from
publication. But this time around, there
doesn't seem to be any serious effort to
extend Disney's copyright for several
reasons. First, each version of Mickey
Mouse has a separate copyright, so only
the Steamboat Willie version will enter
the public domain in 2024. Second, Disney
has clearly diversified its stable of
copyrighted characters. Third, copyright
activists have out-organized Hollywood.
And fourth, it's unlikely the public
would accept a copyright extension
beyond 95 years. So enjoy your day Mickey, because soon you will belong to your adoring public.
What do you think? Will
Disney let its copyrights on Mickey
expire? Let us know in our poll. Also, let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.